5 uhr 30
beim obst und gemüsehändler fuhrmann
sind sie schon seit drei stunden auf den
beinen
die früchte müssen schnell zu den kunden
hotels und restaurants in berlin
der chef muss besonders hochwertige ware
liefern aber immer sehr günstig seien
ein bisschen ärgert ihn dass nahrung
sagt er werde hierzulande nicht richtig
geschätzt
das eigentlich genau andersrum ist
achten die menschen mehr auf die
lebensmittel als auf das auto zum
beispiel aber wir deutschen sind da
glaube ich etwas
warum weiß ich nicht aber wir gucken
halt eher aufs auto als auf die
lebensmittel dieser preiskampf sagt er
mache viele in der branche kaputt
allen voran landwirte die schweine oder
milch liefern
seit gut einem jahr müssen sie zu
niedrigpreisen verkaufen mit etwa 30
prozent weniger einnahmen
grund für die niedrigen preise 2015
wurde die strenge milchquote abgeschafft
die bauern dürfen nun so viel
produzieren wie sie wollen und das taten
sie um es auf dem weltmarkt zu verkaufen
zum beispiel nach china
doch das wollten auch andere etwa
neuseeländische landwirte bei
gleichzeitig der konsum in china
stagniert bleiben viele deutsche bauern
auf ihrer milch sitzen
sie müssen preise senken um überhaupt
noch zu verkaufen
ähnlich beim schweinefleisch nur dass
hier die europäische union mit ihrem
embargo gegen russland den bauern einen
großen absatzmarkt genommen hat zuhause
überangebot und preisverfall der
bauernverband schlägt alarm
derzeit schreiben unsere milchbauern
unserer schweinehalter nur rote zahlen
deswegen kann man nur den
lebensmitteleinzelhandel appellieren
hier seine verantwortung gerecht zu
werden denn wir wollen der heimische
landwirtschaft erhalten
supermärkte und lebensmittelgeschäfte
sollen höhere preise verlangen fordern
sie und die auch an die bauern
weitergeben
denn die bekämen im laufe der jahre
immer weniger
zum vergleich milchbauern zum beispiel
verdienten 1970 von jedem euro der im
laden eingenommen wurde
fast die hälfte heutzutage ist es nur
noch ein viertel profitiert also der
handel die händler verteidigen sich die
konkurrenz sei groß und damit auch der
preisdruck und sie hätten fixe kosten
die schlicht bleiben egal wie hoch die
einkaufspreise sind man hat natürlich
insofern eigene eigene interne kosten
man hat logistikkosten man hat bei
frischeprodukten wie frisch gehalten
werden müssen natürlich auch eine
energie kosten für die kühlung man hat
marketingkosten die eingerechnet werden
müssen
und natürlich hat auch ein lebensmittel
handelsunternehmen das rechten gewinn zu
machen an den produkten und natürlich
würde ich auch einen gewinn
einkalkulieren
beim fruchthändler fuhrmann haben sie
seit jahren relativ stabile preise
die letzten wagen mit dem obst und
gemüse gehen heute morgen ins luxushotel
adlon ein anspruchsvoller kunde den sie
schon seit 15 jahren halten können und
zwar vor allem mit einer besonders hohen
qualität